Sometimes a new exciting opportunity presents
itself, when we are completely happy about
our existing life situation.
If that happens, we are forced to think about
opportunity costs.
This is because when we
look at the new opportunity,
we compare it with our current situation and
think about what is at stake if we would go
for it.
This often happens without us being able to
see the full picture.
Economists define opportunity cost as the
benefit we forego, as we trade-off one alternative
to keep another.
— hoping we make the best choice.
Although they are often less obvious and sometimes
speculative, opportunity costs can be huge,
therefore, learning about them makes sense.
Imagine that we are trying to calculate the
true cost of going to college.
One factor can be tuition, which in our case
is 10,000 dollars.
Since that’s our only cost, you might conclude
that the cost of college is 10,000 dollars
a year.
But to economists, that's not quite right.
Because we have to add the money we could
have earned by working, instead of attending
college.
Let’s say that by working full-time in a
local restaurant, you can earn $20,000 a year
.
The true costs of going to college are, therefore,
$10,000 tuition plus $20,000 in opportunity
costs.
By studying for a degree, we trade off 30,000
dollars a year.
Although, that's only half the story because
it also goes the other way around.
Assuming we go to college for four years,
we trade-off $120,000 for an education that
leaves us with empty pockets, many ideas and
a degree.
However, once we are better educated, we might
be able to make $40,000 as managers instead
of the $20,000 in service.
In such a case, not going to college ends
up being much more expensive.
Do you understand the concept?
Show us!
Calculate the opportunity costs of a high
school student who drops the idea of earning
a degree in medicine, and instead chooses
to help in the family business.
The cost for tuition and living is $2,000
a month.
It takes a total of 6 years to finish university.
After obtaining her degree she works in the
field of medicine for 34 years earning $10,000
a month and spending $3,000 on monthly living
expenses.
If she is entering the family business she
earns $3,500 a month right away for the next
40 years with zero living expenses.
What’s financially the better choice?
Post your calculations in the
comments below!